.
>> BUT IT SAVES EVERYONE ELSE
SO, I'M JULIE, THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THIS MORNING, DEMOCRATS
STILL WAITING ON A FORMAL
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN ON WHETHER OR NOT HE'S
GOING TO RUN FOR REELECTION,
BUT IT NOW HERE'S THAT ONE OF
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN
HIS LIFE IS ACTUALLY ALL IN.
CNN HAS NOW LEARNED THAT FIRST
LADY, JILL BIDEN, IS SUPPORTIVE
OF HER HUSBAND RUNNING FOR
ANOTHER TERM.
THAT'S NOTABLE, GIVEN SHE IS
LIKELY ONE OF THE MOST DECISIVE
VOICES IN HIS ORBIT.
CNN'S KATE BENNETT REPORTS THAT
DESPITE BEING ONES BEING
SKEPTICAL ABOUT ANOTHER
CAMPAIGN, JOE BIDEN IS NOW
ENCOURAGED BY THE RESULTS OF
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS, AND IS
NOW READY TO.
GO --
40% OF DEMOCRATIC VOTERS SAID
YES.
THAT'S NOT AS STRONG AS WHERE
BIDEN WAS AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR, BUT IT IS A LITTLE
BIT STRONGER THAN WHAT HE WAS
OVER THE SUMMER, JUST 25%.
HIS POTENTIAL OPPONENT, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IS NOT FEARING
HIS WEALTH HIS PARTY.
HE'S ACTUALLY SEEING THE
REVERSE OF THAT TREND, BECAUSE
AMONG REPUBLICANS, AND THOSE
WHO LEAN TO THE RIGHT, ONLY 38%
WANT TRUMP TO BE THEIR NOMINEE,
EVEN MORE STRIKING ONE OF THOSE
SAME VOTERS WERE ASKED WHO
SHOULD BE THE NOMINEE, WHO'S
THE NEXT PERSON.
THE CLEAR LEADER AND CLEAR
FLAVORED, WAS FLORIDA GOVERNOR,
RON DESANTIS.
53% SAY THAT THEY PREFER ANYONE
BUT TO TRUMP.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS MAGGIE HABERMAN, CNN'S
POLITICAL ANALYST AND OF COURSE,
FROM THE NEW YORK TIMES.
I FEEL LIKE YOU CAN KIND OF
HEAR THE SCREAMS FROM
MAR-A-LAGO FROM HERE OVER THOSE
NUMBERS.
>> I DON'T THINK ANY OF THIS IS
MAKING DONALD TRUMP HAPPY AND
THE CNN POLL LOOKS LIKE WHAT
WE'VE SEEN WITH OTHER POLLS.
THIS IS CLEARLY A TREND.
DONALD TRUMP'S CALLING CARD IS
STRENGTH, AND BEING SEEN AS
BEING SHOWN WITHIN HIS PARTY.
WHEN THAT STARTS TO ERODE, IT'S
VERY HARD FOR HIM TO KEEP OTHER
PEOPLE AT BAY.
HE'S THE ONLY PERSON WHO IS
RUNNING RIGHT NOW.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW THAT, CAITLIN,
BECAUSE HE'S DONE NO ADVANCE.
I CAN'T REALLY REMEMBER THE
LAST TIME I'VE SEEN EVENTS AND
DO LITERALLY NOTHING.
I'M TOLD IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
NEXT MONTH.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT WHERE
TRUMP WANTED TO BE.
>> HE PUT OUT A SURVEY THE
OTHER DAY, I SHOULD NOTE, I GET
ALL THE REPORTERS --
WE GET HE PUT OUT A SURVEY
ASKING WHERE HE SHOULD GO TO
HIS FIRST RALLY.
SO CLEARLY HE HASN'T PICKED A
LOCATION YET.
BUT IT'S BEEN A MONTH NOW, TO
THE DAY.
>> THE RALLIES ARE EXPENSIVE.
I DON'T KNOW MUCH MONEY IS
RAISING, BUT THE RALLIES COST A
LOT OF MONEY.
IF YOU START SEEING DON TRUMP
DURING FRIENDS THAT ARE NOT
RALLY, THAT IS TELLING ABOUT
THE STATE OF HIS CAMPAIGN IN A
DIFFERENT WAY.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> BUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT, IT WAS
LACKLUSTER.
THE ENERGY WAS LOW.
HE'S NOT REALLY DOING ANYTHING.
HE'S TEASING STUFF BUT I MEAN,
HONESTLY IT'S KIND OF, WHO
CARES?
AT OF SIGHT OUT OF MIND.
>> THERE WAS A COLUMN THE SEA
BY JOSH LOMBARDI THAT THOUGHT
WAS DEAD ON WAS THAT ELON MUSK
IS ACTUALLY REALLY HURTING
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
HE'S MADE HIMSELF TO THE MID
CHARACTER ON TWITTER, BOTH AS
THE VILLAIN AND AS THE MONGOL
LINER.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY DOING
TRUMPIAN THINGS, WHY DO NEED
TRUMP?
>> SO FASCINATING.
>> IT'S TRUE.
WE'RE SO EARLY IN A CAMPAIGN AT
THIS POINT, IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE
GONNA SEE A LOT OF CANDIDATES
JOUSTING.
TRUMP GOT IN EARLIER THAN --
>> WE TALK ABOUT THE CNN
POLLING THAT I THOUGHT WAS SO
INTERESTING.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO TRUMP BIDEN REMATCH,
IT'S THAT THEY DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY WANT.
>> TOTALLY, TOTALLY.
>> ISN'T THAT KIND OF WORSE FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT?
NOT ONLY DO WE NOT WANT YOU, WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO ELSE WE
WANT, JUST NOT YOU.
>> BIDEN IS A SITTING PRESIDENT,
SO HE IS JUST DEFINITIONAL IN
THE STRONG POSITION.
I'M SORRY, HE JUST IS.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN HIS
PARTY WHO PRIVATELY WILL SAY
THEY DON'T WANT HIM TO RUN,
UNTIL THOSE PEOPLE ARE START
SAYING THAT PUBLICLY, BIDEN IS
IN GOOD SHAPE.
>> THERE'S A --
BIDEN IS WINNING.
I'M SORRY, BIDEN IS WINNING.
I DON'T KNOW THE POLLING IS SO
DOING BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
INFLATION REDUCTION, AT LOWER
BATH GAS PRICES, LOWER --
THE RESTRUCTURE MARRIAGE ACT, I
MEAN BIDEN IS WINNING.
SO THE POLLING, I DON'T KNOW IF
THE POLLING IS OFF OR IF IT'S
GONNA SHOW WHEN HE DOES, IT I
THINK HE'S GONNA RUN.
IF HIS WIFE SAYS RUN, HE'S
GONNA DO.
IT >> ALL SIGNS ARE THAT BIDEN
IS GOING TO RUN.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE IS
SENDING A CONFLICTING SIGNALS
WHICH IS, DON'T WRITE THE
STORIES THAT HE'S NOT RUNNING,
AND YET HERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ALL THE STORIES THAT HE IS
DEBATING WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
THAT'S THEIR OWN ISSUE.
BUT I AGREE WITH YOU, AT THE
MOMENT IS THAT ALL SIGNS ARE
HE'S GOING TO RUN.
HE CERTAINLY HAS WINDS AT HIS
BACK IN A WAY THAT DONALD TRUMP
JUST DOES NOT.
ONE THING THAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT ONE OF THE POLLS
YESTERDAY, THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL POLL SHOWED BIDEN
GETTING BEAT BY DESANTIS.
I WANT TO CAVEAT THAT WERE TWO
YEARS OUT, TEARS OUT DON'T
REALLY TELL US A TON.
BUT THEY DO TELL US A SNAPSHOT
IN TIME.
BIDEN IS STRONG AGAINST TRUMP.
--
IT REMINDS ME A LITTLE WHAT WE
SAW IN 2016.
IS THAT HILLARY CLINTON AND
DONALD TRUMP ARE THE TWO WHO
COULD BE EACH OTHER, AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE
GOING FORWARD IF IT'S NOT TRUMP
FOR BIDEN.
JUST SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
>> YEAH THAT'S SOMETHING THE
WHITE HOUSE IS WATCHING.
TRUMP IS KNOWN, DESANTIS HE'S
GOT A LOT OF PRAISE, BUT WE
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW HOW HE
WOULD.
FAIR >> REALLY IMPORTANT TO
BEAR IN, MIND WE DON'T KNOW.
>> WE HAVE NO CLUE, MAYBE HE'LL
DO BETTER THAN WE THINK, MAYBE
HE'LL DO WORSE.
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK
THE WHITE HOUSE IS WATCHING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW SENSE
DESANTIS'S WEAK POINT IN A
SENSE LIKE THAT.
AS YOU SAID, WE'RE SO FAR OUT.
I THINK SOME VOTERS ARE LIKE,
LET'S JUST WAIT.
A FIGHT THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IS KEVIN MCCARTHY ON
CAPITOL HILL WHO IS LITERALLY
FIGHTING FOR HIS POLITICAL
LIFE.
THERE WAS A MOMENT YESTERDAY
WHERE --
ASKED HIM ABOUT THIS NUMBER,
THE FIGHT TO GET UP TO 18 AND
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> IT WOULD HAVE BEEN SO HARD
FOR YOU TO GET 218 VOTES TO
BECOME SPEAKER WHEN YOU HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPARENTLY
LOBBYING ON YOUR BEHALF.
YOU HAVE MEETING WITH MEMBERS
OF THE FREEDOM CAUCUS.
BUT THE VOTES JUST AREN'T THERE,
WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR YOU?
>> YOU KNOW IT'S AMAZING TO ME?
HERE WE ARE WITH THE BIGGEST
THINGS GOING ON ON THE SPENDING
AND I CAN ALWAYS COUNT ON YOU
FOR THE MOST INAPPROPRIATE
QUESTION.
>> IT'S NOT INAPPROPRIATE AT
ALL?
>> IT'S NOT AN INAPPROPRIATE
QUESTION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A VERY
LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
IT'S A PRETTY MILD ONE AND IT
WAS ASKED VERY POLITELY.
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHY HE
CAN'T GET.
THERE HE'S GOING TO GET ASKED
THAT QUESTION OVER AND OVER
AGAIN UNTIL HE ACTUALLY DOES.
I'M OF THE OPINION THAT HE
PROBABLY WILL, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HE GIVES THE
HOLDOUTS.
I DON'T HAVE THE HOLDOUTS JUST
GET CRUSHED BY THE MODERATES
WHO MCCARTHY IS TRYING TO
QUIETLY LEAN ON RIGHT NOW.
BUT THIS IS NOT GOING WELL, AND
HE HAS A VERY SLIM MAJORITY
AMONG REPUBLICANS.
SO, THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
--
>> EVEN IF HE WINS, HE STILL
HAS THE SAME CAUCUS THAT'S
INCREDIBLY FRACTIOUS.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S LIKE A
VICTORY IN EVERYTHING'S DONE.
IT'S A VICTORY AND IT'S JUST
GETTING STARTED.
>> JOHN BOEHNER'S CACKLING
SOMEWHERE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH THIS ARE LOOKING AT
THIS LIKE WELL, NOT ME, GOOD
FOR YOU, ENJOY THIS.
>> I THINK THAT ANSWER SHOWS
JUST HOW SENSITIVE HE IS ABOUT
IT AND IT WAS THE RIGHT
QUESTION.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, HE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET THAT.
I MEAN THAT WAS A DUMB, THAT
WAS A SNARKY ANSWER.
>> IT